yeah i
i would say just a as a small aside
that's why reading
as i'm almost done with uh the rise and
fall of the third reich
oh yeah is uh it it's uh
refreshes the resets the palette of your
understanding of what is good and evil
in the world
that i think is really useful
now like you know what helps me be
really positive
and almost naive on twitter uh
and in the world is by just studying
history yeah
and and uh comparing it to how amazing
things are
uh today but in that time
what would you do
what does the brave mind do
and not just uh
acts of bravery but how do you be
effective in that that's something i
often think about it's sometimes easy to
be an activist
in terms of just saying stuff it's hard
to be
effective at your activism one of the
big questions historians have
uh constantly is how did this happen a's
to make sure it doesn't happen again but
this is germany
this is not some kind of weirdo cult
nation
they're very advanced very in the land
of poets and philosophers
how did it get to that point that
they're just
shooting children and everyone's
cheering for this and and specifically
on the anti-semitism and the holocaust
but just the
whole town terrorism the cult of hitler
and just this whole kind of
thing and there's this sorry starting to
draw but there's two sides i don't know
if you want to separate them one is
the totalitarianism and the the entire
the entirety is the nazi regime
and then there's the holocaust which is
like
you know going i would say
like very specifically
as i think you're about to describe is
like you know targeting
jews very much so i don't know if you
see those as two separate things i think
they're very interconnected but i think
if you look at it everyone thinks that
they'd be the ones
putting up anne frank but if you look at
the numbers they'd be the ones
calling the stasi on her or whoever the
people were at the time
and not the stasi obviously uh and
patting themselves in the back for it
so sorry to pause on that it's a really
important thing if you're listening to
this
that and you were not you were in
germany at the time
you would have likely been willing to
commit
or at least keep a blind eye to the
violence against jews like
you have to really sit with that idea
that you would have been somebody
who just sees this and is not bothered
by it
and also very likely kind of understand
this
as a necessary evil or even unnecessary
good
yeah and i think people think
that they would be the abolitionists or
marching on selma the numbers don't
add that add up to that at all and i
think the question would be like what
social i my friend was on tinder my
friend matt who's a great dude
and the question was what's the most
controversial opinion you have this is
new york
and the girl wrote i hate trump and
what people perceive themselves as being
courageous in
saying and doing and what is the actual
social costs of you saying or doing this
are two very disconnected things and
we're also trained
by corporate media to have completely
vapid
uninteresting banal ideas and yet regard
ourselves as revolutionaries
you know there are people who still in
new york will take pride
because they have a gay friend and it's
like first of all
who cares but second of all you are not
a hero
and that person is not your prop by the
way that's another big problem
you